oh sorry give me a second I'm just
looking at some of the worst most
obscene material ever posted on the
Internet first published in 1928 Lady
Chatterley's Lover was banned in the
u.s. until 1959 due to its sexual
content now it's considered one of th
Lawrence's great works but if it was
obscene until fifty years ago and is now
a masterpiece it makes you wonder about
what works we consider obscene today but
will be revered come 2060 every anything
that's that can develop a constituency
for people to want other people to
behave in that way is now open in this
society where the majority can impose
its standards and behavior patterns upon
a minority and that's a very bad
precedent to set that's John saliano
stole the honor doesn't do literature he
makes porn videos and he's being
prosecuted by the United States federal
government on multiple counts of
obscenity for producing and distributing
the fetish films milk [__] and storms
quarters to target practice as well as a
trailer for another porn collection
if convicted on all counts and given
maximum sentences he could spend the
rest of his life in prison government
agents bought the films on the
adults-only website for Stolley on his
company evil angel productions and had
them shipped to that hotbed of moral
rectitude Washington DC in the interests
of full disclosure let me add that
staliano is a donor to Reason Foundation
the nonprofit that publishes reason TV
federal prosecutions for obscenity of
rare but Stolley Otto's case follows
recent actions against other
pornographers such as max hardcore who
was found guilty of selling obscene
materials in 2008 and Lizzie Borden Rob
black of extreme associates who pled
guilty in 2009 after six years of court
battles talking about pornography and
obscenity makes a lot of people
uncomfortable but it's precisely this
sort of boundary stretching expression
that often ends up defining where our
free speech rights are most imperiled
and let's be clear we're not talking
about snuff films or child pornography
which are by definition
the evidence of criminal acts I didn't
know I was breaking the law you know the
first thing is you know we're a
government of laws and not men if you
don't if you don't have a law that's
written that says that okay if you do
this you will go to jail then then
that's a good law if you have a law that
says well you know we might say that
this is obscene or we might say that's
obscene but we won't really know in
advance we're just gonna maybe decide to
prosecute you that's the first number
one bad thing about this situation is
that I didn't know I was breaking the
law obscenity is not covered by the
First Amendment since 1973 a work is
considered obscene if taken as a whole
it appeals mostly to the prurient
interest of an average person applying
contemporary community standards and if
it's deemed to depict sexual or
excretory functions in a patently
offensive way that has no serious
literary artistic political or
scientific value that's never a clear
call the exact same film or novel or
song that might be castigated as obscene
in one part of the country could be
praised as great art in another
pornography and obscenity are
notoriously subjective and all the more
so when legal definitions rely on the
term community standards especially in
the age of the internet what this
community standard even mean staliano is
based in California and is being
prosecuted in DC for videos but in
cyberspace
so what community standards should be
used this much is certain
Stolley oughtta wasn't pushing these
films on anybody who didn't want them
some people don't like porno and it
should not be in their faces I've always
been very uncomfortable with with with
some people who make porno movies that
want to say oh this is free speech you
know and I'm out there and I'm just
talking about it all the time
That's not me you know I make my porno
movies for the people that love porno
throw my fans there other people I make
it for for some other people that want
to help get more publicity and stuff
that's not interesting to me I don't
want porno to be in the face of people
who don't want to see it in an era of
seemingly limitless free expression
online it's easy to ignore the
prosecution of pornographers yet that
would be a mistake
like me you may have never purchased the
porn DVD in your life but staliano makes
a strong argument that his case has far
broader implications
reason why I think this case is
important is because it's it's another
area where the government thinks they
should be able to run our lives and this
is certainly an important area where
it's art that we consume it's recreation
that we consume and it's the principle
that the government can come in and say
behave this way and they could easily
extend that from looking at porn to
consuming fast foods to smoking
cigarettes oh they already did that to
all sorts of things john staliano is
effectively facing the rest of his life
in prison for selling movies made by and
for consenting adults his case is
pending in staliano has vowed to fight
his case all the way to the Supreme
Court if need be will storms quarters to
be considered a cinematic masterpiece in
50 years
maybe not but here's hoping that the
guidelines governing free expression
will have disappeared completely or at
least evolved to a point where nobody's
livelihood or freedom depends on the
random opinions of 12 strangers called
to serve on a jury and now if you'll
excuse me I want to get back to that
brilliant bit of prose found on the
internet that only a generation ago was
considered so horrified that it couldn't
legally be sold in these United States
Lady Chatterley's logic for reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie
but then she soon learned to hold him to
keep him there inside her when his
crisis was over and there he was
generous and curiously poked he's
we support all these people - I go to
sleep teeth a photon crusher do these do